what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to how to get a woman
obsessed with you by alpha male
strategies uh before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell the way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos um this is gonna be interesting
because
i guess i gotta see like would i be
obsessed i just wanna know
also also one more thing before i start
i just dropped my first sweatshirt line
i'm not wearing it now but the design is
actually really cool it's like very
simple um it's like a teal blue with a
black sweatshirt and i don't know my
boyfriend literally loves his so
yeah please buy them if you like the
channel it really helps me
with my move to london okay
what's up people
so today i'm gonna teach you how to get
a woman crazy obsessed with you
now guys
before i even [ __ ] start let me say
this
this video here is pure evil
you understand what i'm saying this is a
pure evil video
if you use this [ __ ] you're an evil
person damn
but we don't love them hoes so let's
talk about it
all right
so guys what's up
first thing you need to know is
you have to if you go back and watch all
my videos the first thing you need to
know is
you've got to have the ultimate
confidence
understand what i'm saying the ultimate
swagger
now if you don't got that you can't get
to the obsessed part
and what i say the only way you're going
to get to that swagger part is by being
on your purpose
and feeling great about yourself that's
where all that confidence and swag are
going to come from and they don't just
come from the thing out despite what
you've been [ __ ] told i'm telling you
it ain't it comes from the
self-improvement hitting the gym and
getting your [ __ ] together that's gonna
give you the confidence to make you feel
like you have options which gives you
the confidence to not take a warm [ __ ]
which is gonna come across as confident
you understand what i'm saying so when
she go to doing her [ __ ] test you got
the [ __ ] balls to stand up to her
because you feel like hey i look good
i'm doing good for myself i'm not gonna
take your [ __ ] all right so that's the
first and foremost guys after you've met
her looks standard and all this all the
attraction you gotta have the confidence
on swag the confidence got to be swag
you gotta feel like i can replace this
[ __ ] at any time okay i i don't
appreciate the language
not a fan of the language but
i do agree confidence is important
it is all right don't then happen
without that that's got to be number one
all right first thing you need to know
guys is no matter who you are unless
you're a rich celebrity or something
the average man gonna have to do all the
pursuing in the beginning unless a woman
has crazy high initial interest i'm
talking at least 80 percent unless
she has high initial interest you're
going to be doing most of the pursuing
and you also can gauge a woman's
interest by that and to knowing how far
you got to go before you get the ass if
you got a woman that never calls you in
between the weeks her interest is kind
of low if you got a woman that's texting
you two three times in the in uh the
first week or so you got a woman that's
interesting it's very [ __ ] high that
means
you're just the way times in the first
week that's it
[ __ ] okay the way when she look at you
you make her [ __ ] tingle it ain't
nothing you can do about that there
ain't no game or nothing that just means
you as you are your image your swag just
does it for her all right but let's just
assume that the woman doesn't have
sky-high initial interest the average
guy
you're gonna need to know that most of
uh most men gonna have to do all the
pursuing at the very beginning probably
the first two weeks sometimes three all
right but this is the big problem with a
lot of guys [ __ ] up at
all right
guys
they back off way too [ __ ] soon all
right so
if a woman if you are texting a woman
once a week to go out on a date and say
by the second week or the third week
she starts hitting you up once a week
and then you feel like okay i can back
all the way off now she's pursuing you
it don't go that way guys
pursuing is like a dimmer switch not on
off switch so you gotta slowly back away
so the dynamics go like this you're
doing a hundred percent she's doing zero
percent
you she hers comes up like this right
here
and then you come down to once a week
and her steady comes up so you always do
once a week no matter what
and hers increase yours don't don't
change or nothing you stay at once a
week which you know the beginning is 100
because she ain't gonna
chase you at all
but as her interest raises she you're
gonna stay here once a week and her is
gonna start to come up to where she's
eventually
going to be pursuing you every [ __ ]
day all right
she's gonna be calling to check on you
every [ __ ] day now once it gets to a
hundred percent
that's when you back off when she starts
doing a hitting you up every day that's
when you back off don't back off until
she's hitting you up every day up to
that point
you make sure you hit her once a week
and if you back off damn that's evil
oh my god that's evil oh my god too soon
before the woman has developed an
attachment to you an emotional
attachment to you she'll just back up or
lose interest i understand what i'm
saying you got before you can back up
completely you got to wait till she has
her interest at 100
so you can't stop uh texting her calling
her once a week until she's hitting you
up every [ __ ] day if you back off
before then that's way too soon now guys
it was once upon a time where if you had
sex with a woman
that was all the emotional investment
you needed from a woman to get her to
pursue you because she felt like hey i
gave this dude my body so she felt like
she was invested to get more get a
relationship
it's 2018 guys that [ __ ] don't hold true
no more a woman will [ __ ] you you hit
hub next week and she don't want to see
you no more because you didn't make her
come you understand what i'm saying so
that the sex uh emotional attachment
don't work no more so what you got to
get a woman doing these days is you got
to get her emotionally attached to
chasing your validation
now guys
you know i talk a lot about validation
and so i want to talk about validation
right now
the reason a woman wants your validation
is because essentially you're not giving
her validation essentially her never
feeling good enough you understand what
i'm saying and that has nothing to do
with you that has everything to do with
her that's her ego won't let it be you
know saying that has nothing to do with
you that's her ego don't want to accept
the defeat
see most women date these beta males who
worship the ground they work walk on to
when they run into a dude that makes
them feel lower it can't be and they
can't take it and they're determined to
get your validation you understand what
i'm saying they they can't stand to lose
one so she's not obsessed with chasing
you she's obsessed with chasing that
validation she's obsessed with the fact
this guy ain't gonna act like i'm
beneath him you understand what i'm
saying so it has nothing to do with you
this has everything to do with her just
chasing your validation
okay i disagree here because i mean i
think like he's right once you get a
girl attached
like then
you know it's well it's because i think
girls are just like confused if you go
from like being super interested to just
not at all
because we don't work like that like we
don't go from being super interested a
guy to not interested at all the next
normally i want to say like in
generalities
but and so we're like well why like what
did what did i do whatever
so
oh my god this stuff is kind of evil but
i don't think that a girl unless she's
like super interested as you is really
going to chase your validation to be
honest
and that's why i tell you guys to never
give it to her and all and [ __ ] and and
and i will say too if you have to play
these games like you don't want a girl
you have to play these games with i'm
sure like
he's trying to do the rotation thing so
i guess like go do that but i don't know
if you're trying to find a wife i would
not
suggest these games new subscribers that
don't know what validation is validation
is compliments wanting to spend a lot of
time with her talking to her a long time
on the phone all these are saying i
really like you that's what every woman
women have no self-esteem guys i know
when you see them outside with that mask
on and they got they walk in the ass
true
i have like
zero confidence at all something like
they're seddy they really are low
self-esteem creatures that's why they
need attention from men constantly to
feel good about themselves because they
have very low self-esteem so when
they're dating a guy and he won't get
them do i need attention
i'm really not into like the instagram
like showing off my body type stuff but
i like like talking to people conversing
having a good chit chat compliment or he
won't get him no signs that he's really
into them it really [ __ ] with their
head and their psyche and so they can't
take that
um
they can't take that they need every
[ __ ] guy to like them they can't
stand the date of god that makes them
feel like he's beneath them
now so now let's say you don't switch
the tables that only works if you're a
guy that she likes
you you can't just like reject a girl
and then expect her to be like hurt and
mad that you rejected her because
like if she doesn't like you doesn't
matter you got her doing 100 of the
pursuing now all right this takes time
guys this is going to take at least two
to three months
some you guys back off way too [ __ ]
soon this is not going to happen
overnight you got to wait
till she developed i agree with that
that takes time i like 100 agree with
that
an emotional attachment to chasing your
validation this is going to take
probably two to three months probably
closer to three with the savages we
dealing with today these [ __ ] girls
are [ __ ] wolverines then they body
count high as hell so if you thinking
like oh i [ __ ] her real good she gonna
be attached to me you better think again
all right cuz these girls be where where
do you meet these women
you count as high as [ __ ] these days now
that you got her doing 100
because you making her feel like she's
she's starting to feel like she's losing
you you understand what i'm saying so
you didn't validate her now you're going
the other way all right now you go
another way and understand now she's not
obsessed with you she's only obsessed
with getting that [ __ ] validation she
need that [ __ ] devin give it to me
give me that [ __ ] validation god damn
it she's obsessed with getting that
[ __ ] validation you gonna validate me
goddammit that's what she thinking so
now you finna go the other way now
the secret to getting her really
obsessed with you is now you got to go
you you finna be real evil now you finna
tear her self-esteem down you understand
what i'm saying you finna not make her
feel like she's not worthy of you i
understand what i'm saying so
well that's that's mean what now
you'll set a time to see her so say
saturday you'll set a time to see her
and friday your council like hey i can't
do that
i'm going out with my friends
you i don't know any of you guys know
what that does to a woman you when you
do some [ __ ] like that you make her feel
worthless you make her feel like she's
no no nothing like a priority to you you
understand what i'm saying but it's only
gonna make her chase you more now guys
doing [ __ ] like this this right here
understand that all this [ __ ] only works
if when a woman is with you
your personality is on point your
confidence on point your swagger's on
point this [ __ ] don't work if when she's
around you she's not having a good time
you understand what i'm saying like
you're a pain in the ass you got to be
in your sexy suave move
to make her feel like a real woman to
make her feel real feminine so you got
to be extra masculine you got to be a
man's man you understand you got to be
super swag so when she's around you she
gets that tingling inside her no woman
is going to go through all this [ __ ]
for a guy that's just okay understand
what i'm saying your personality got to
be that's true that's true a girl is
only going to put up with this stuff
like that's true on point the way she
feel when she with you got to be on
[ __ ] point ain't nobody finna call
you all the time and let you flake on
them and do all this [ __ ] and when
they get with you they ain't having a
good time now when i say having a good
time i'm not talking about expensive
dates i'm talking about we just sitting
on the couch and just the way you carry
yourself makes my [ __ ] tingle you
understand what i'm saying that's just
the way you make me feel when i'm with
you you understand what i'm saying
if you give her that certain tingle
she'll keep chasing your [ __ ]
validation if you just an average dude
it ain't gonna happen so you're gonna
have to have that personality on swag
you're gonna have to have your
confidence on swag if not
it won't work ain't no woman to go
through all this [ __ ] for a guy she
barely like you understand what i'm
saying the only way it works if you make
her [ __ ] tingle physically and mentally
i do not like the way he is
describing this i would i would choose
different words but you got to stimulate
her mind and her [ __ ] [ __ ] you
understand what i'm saying and make sure
she come by doing the [ __ ] four play
i told you most women cannot come with
your damn dick you got to make her come
with foreplay so if you're making her
calm in the bedroom and you're making
her call in her mind like they say a
woman got two [ __ ] one between her
leg and one uphill if you're making her
calm with both of those mentally and
between her legs she'll stay chasing
your validation if you ain't [ __ ] her
right and then you ain't stimulating her
mind ain't no woman to keep pursuing
your ass [ __ ] your validation you
understand all right so like i said
so like i said you'll cancel the date
say hey i gotta hang out my friends i
can't see you this weekend all right
you'll say some [ __ ] like that you'll
skip weeks seeing her like you won't
you'll tell i can't see this weekend i
got something else to do
all this makes her feel like she's not
good enough she'll call you sometimes
you don't even return a call or text
she'll hit you up maybe the next day or
the day after and she's like hey you
ain't never you see my call just say i
was busy doing something like that don't
you know don't get into it too much i
was busy i was gonna get around to
calling but
essentially guys you're making her feel
worthless you're making her feel like
she's unimportant
all this is tearing her self-esteem down
which i said guys is really evil but
like i told you we don't love them hoes
so it's really evil but you gotta so you
don't win do you think girls that he
messes with like see these
from here a hundred percent pursuing to
now she's doing 100 pursuing and on top
of that you're tearing herself
self-esteem down
all right now
it's gonna come times
well in between uh you know due to
the structure of how women think these
days she's gonna look and say man i call
him all the time he never calls me
and at some point she at times she gonna
pull back and you might not hear from
two three four days she gonna do it she
gonna do it because in her head she's
like hey i'm doing all the pursuing this
is not right he does nothing you gotta
be on your purpose and really not give a
[ __ ] about that [ __ ] now if deep down
you really care
you can't hold true on this this only
holds true if you really focus on your
purpose and you don't give a [ __ ] she
ever call back or not because please
believe it's going to be weeks in that
way she she's not going to pursue you
you know because she she's determined to
make you start at least contribute to
some of the pursuing you don't do it you
wait till she calls and takes you all
right so like i said guys how you do it
is you start off
you're going to do 100 pursuing
she's not gonna pursue it all
you slow you you keep you maintain your
once a week
she's gonna come up and hus is gonna go
to twice a week three times a week four
times a week so eventually she's doing
all the [ __ ] pursuing that's when you
stop 100 percent all right you got to be
in your confident masculine uh swag
for her to value your value date
validation if you don't have that she
don't value your validation so [ __ ] your
validation all right and when she's
around you you got to make her her mind
and her [ __ ] tingle all right if you
can't do that then [ __ ] your validation
all right so ain't nobody gonna ain't no
a woman is not gonna chase your
validation if it doesn't mean anything
all right and a one that's true that is
a woman is not gonna chase your
validation if it doesn't mean anything
understand this guy she's not
obsessed with chasing you
and she don't give a [ __ ] about you
she's only upset i
i would disagree with that
i
i've seen some girl oh my god
no some girls it is the guy we're
chasing that validation because it'll
ease her ego her ego don't want to take
a l that it's a guy that's treating me
like [ __ ] it has nothing to do with you
it's all her that's how narcissistic
women are it has nothing to do with you
she's only doing all this pursuing and
chasing to chase your validation to ease
her ego because she can't stand up
without of a man i really really want
her
all right
and like i said at the end
you're gonna go the other way you're
gonna you're gonna pull back your
entrance all the way you're not gonna
see her every week
uh you're gonna you're gonna cancel
dates with him you're gonna lay in bed
sometimes with her and not want to have
sex with her telling you tired or
something that's gonna make her feel
unattractive if you understand what i'm
saying essentially that's mean
that's so mean
you're tearing her self-esteem down now
all right and like i said guys these are
evil tactics so like i said
we don't love them holes over here baby
so like i said you know you know where
to go if you're looking for a wife
because we don't love them hoes over
here we don't give a [ __ ] about their
self-esteem [ __ ] that self-esteem
all
like comment subscribe
oh my god
um oh gosh okay this one
um
i mean there was some truth to that i'm
sure i don't really like like the games
it's just oh my gosh why is this
someone know let me know on the channel
why on earth this zooms in so much when
like it's not the other way
anyways
oh you know what oh my god i figured out
why
oh my god i'm so dumb
oh my god that's better okay yeah i'm
not really like a fan of the games i
feel like why waste your time with all
that when you find a girl that actually
likes you
um but i don't think my channel is the
let me find a rotation channel so
but don't forget to subscribe um to the
channel
like the video leave a comment and buy
my sweatshirts on the link is in the
description i'll talk to you guys next
time